1917 ist ein film von sam mendes dem
ressort von zeiten des aufruhrs american
beauty und der vorleser für einen
kriegsfilm regisseur würde man am ende
ist also nicht unbedingt halten aber
wenn es hat eine besondere idee für
diesen film gehabt
er wollte eben nicht das üblich auf und
abschnitt und gegen schnitt von
verschiedenen kampfszenen und
verschiedenen protagonisten zeigen
sondern er wollte eine einzige
einstellung über zwei stunden aufnehmen
in der der krieg als kontinuierliches
fließendes geschehen aus der sicht von
zwei soldaten dargestellt wird
und genau das hat er mit seinem
kameramann roger deakins auch umgesetzt
sie haben einen bruder im zweiten
bataillon ist er am leben und mit ihrer
hilfe wird es auch so bleibt
sie sind in eine falle geraten ihr
befehl lautet die nachricht zu
überbringen dass der morgendliche
angriff abgesagt ist
falls nicht verlieren wir 1600 mann
darunter ihr bruder die ungeheure
technische meisterleistung die darin
steckt die kann man sich auf youtube in
verschiedenen dreh berichten anschauen
auf der leinwand bringt man vor allen
dingen ganz tief in die erfahrungswelt
und in den erfahrungsraum dieser
soldaten des ersten weltkriegs ein von
den mendes film erzählt
das freilich angepasst
ich glaube ich nicht
ein leben
gewinnspiel an einem tag im frühjahr
1917 zufällig ist es genau der tag an
dem amerika in den ersten weltkrieg
eintrat und so die entscheidung
herbeiführte aber davon wissen unsere
beiden helden zwei britischen soldaten
die eine mission haben mit dem sie ein
blutbad verhindern sollen nicht erst
wieder unsere freunde sieht ganz so aus
luftkampf wer gewinnt wer glaub ich 2
gegen 1
sie haben
sammeln stolpern irren durch eine
mondlandschaft die dann wieder mit
momenten von idylle abwechselt
du bist weiter über felder an die hüften
vorbei durch brennende ruinenstätte da
können sie nicht lange warten sie haben
den verstand verlor durch flüsse müssen
sich schwimmend am ende ihr ziel zu
erreichen
[Musik]
schaffen sie es nicht rechtzeitig
verlieren wir 1600 man kann also sagen
diese geschichte kommt uns bekannt vor
aber die art wie sie erzählt es ist
vollkommen neu wer hat etwas mit den
tiefen eintauchen in eine vergangene
welt zu tun mit im versionen man heute
so sagt aber sie ist kein kunststück ein
stunt keine zaubertricks ist eine
wirkliche kino leistung weil sie eine
wirkliche realität auf der leinwand
erschafft
[Musik]
die realität zu geben eines fernen
krieges in denen wir uns nicht mehr
hinein versetzen können dessen
voraussetzungen dessen emotionen der
sind abläufe uns tief fremd sind der
aber durch diesen film auf eine weise
wieder erweckt wird der einen dann doch
wieder an das alte verbrauchte oft
totgesagte genre des kriegsfilms glauben
lässt was mit 317 eine auferstehung
erlebt
[Musik]
es gibt nur einen weg diesen krieg zu
beenden
er kommt es zum letzten mal
ok
sie scheitern
gibt es ein massaker
viel glück